bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors c'est un
accord un normalement qui concerne à une
enveloppe de 750 milliards d'euros qui
doit normalement être levés sur les
marchés financiers ou non de l'union
européenne c'est donc une dette commune
c'est cela ah oui alors bon
effectivement c'est le point fort de
l'accord qui est de enfin considérer que
cette dette commune on sait que
l'allemagne les pays-bas s'y opposait
depuis très longtemps mais d'ailleurs
depuis la crise de la dette grecque de
on en parle de cette dette commune c'est
vraiment le point fort de cet accord
donc c'est l'idée effectivement qu'on va
pouvoir signer un emprunt un état va
pouvoir signer un emprunt
au nom donc de l'union européenne et pas
au nom pas de l'italie du portugal par
exemple
donc c'est un je dirais que c'est une
première étape vers quelque chose d'un
peu plus de long terme et peut-être je
l'espère une renaissance d'une certaine
façon par le haut de l'europe
c'est vrai que c'est le point fort du
jour et sur les contours de la
redistribution justement de cette
enveloppe sous forme de subventions oui
alors il y a effectivement les 500
milliards de subventions les 250
milliards de prêts qui devront donc être
remboursés pour l'instant on est sur 82
milliards pour l'italie 77 pour
l'espagne 39 pour la france concernant
les prêts évidemment qu'il y à de
lourdes questions qui est qui doit
bénéficier de ces montants comment
suivre également la bonne application
je dirais les bons investissements
comment ce sont des questions qui sont
loin d'être facile parce que très
souvent en europe on a depuis 2012
conditionné un certain nombre de prêts à
des plans d'austérité et à des se dirait
des réformes structurelles qui sont
considérés entre guillemets
plutôt libérale on va dire donc si c'est
une grande nouvelle aujourd'hui si
l'allemagne a fait un grand pas il y a
comme vous le dites le suivi des
ressources qui vont être réalisés sous
conditions et quelles conditions et est
ce que ces conditions vont changer ou
est-ce que c'est toujours une même
orthodoxie un tout petit peu allemande
que l'on connaît bien maintenant depuis
plusieurs années si vous voulez il ya
quand même des pays qui sont opposés à
cet accord la suède l'autriche les
pays-bas le danemark
pourquoi est ce qu'elles s'opposent à
cet accord c'est la crainte et ça
rejoint ce que je viens de dire à
l'instant du laxisme budgétaire
principalement ce sont des pays qui ont
plutôt été toujours du côté des pays à
l'équilibré avec plus de croissance avec
des exigences surtout pour l'allemagne
et les pays-bas d'équilibré budgétaire
de restriction de restriction de rigueur
monétaire également et donc la crainte
c'est tout simplement que des pays plus
j'aime pas le terme laxiste mais des
pays plus risqué en termes de
solvabilité de la dette se retrouvent à
payer des taux d'intérêt très faibles et
en gros qu'un pays comme l'italie le
portugal paie un taux d'intérêts sur un
emprunt européen équivalent à celui de
l'allemagne
et donc ça voudrait dire quelque part
indirectement que les inefficacités
entre guillemets de l'europe sont payés
par l'allemagne par des pays qui
réussissent économiquement mieux si vous
voulez donc il y à une question d'équité
et de d'efficacité économique qui est
posée ce que c'est quand même une europe
divisée qui s'est réuni de façon
virtuelle
aujourd'hui on l'a vu durant plus fort
de la crise sanitaire en europe
ll peine cette europe à se mettre
d'accord pour relancer les économies de
l'union européenne ya quand même
beaucoup de sujets de désaccord et des
divisions bien sûr qu'ils avouent sujet
des accords révision la première c'est
comment est-ce qu'on va financer donc on
peut le financer par effectivement pas
augmenter les impôts taxes gaf a en gros
taxe carbone taxe sur les plastiques et
les entreprises polluantes
ça reste encore toujours une division
importante entre des pays qui estiment
que ben il faut plutôt faire de la
croissance vers de nouveaux secteurs
d'activité plutôt de systématiquement
prélever des impôts
et puis trop d'impôt tué l'impôt et on a
déjà beaucoup en europe on va dire donc
là il ya une première division sur la
façon pour être financés ensuite il ya
une seconde division qui est elle est
extrêmement importante c'est qu'il ya
des pays qui ont des avantages
comparatifs dans l'industrie d'autres
qui ont des avantages comparatifs dans
le secteur éolien
je pense à l'allemagne d'un côté le
portugal de l'autre et donc finalement
qu'est-ce qu'on considère aujourd'hui
comme économiquement important
évidemment que devra faire quelque chose
du fine tuning intelligent sur
l'ensemble des deux pays sur l'ensemble
des avantages comparatifs des pays pour
faire en sorte qu'on puisse créer une
europe un peu plus équilibré mais on
peut pas je dirais que tu nuis à faire
en sorte que seuls quelques pays soit
extrêmement excédentaire en termes de
balance commerciale et d'autres
extrêmement déficitaire sinon on se
retrouve avec un fossé nord-sud
classique que l'on connaît
depuis la crise de la dgac merci
beaucoup à vous pascal l'image bloqués
enseignant à sciences po paris
économiste en chef chez harwell
management